i got them 1.9 trillion dollars relief
so far
i wrote the bill on the environment
listen you pay them more
this is getting really weird
[Music]
[Applause]
yes the only phrase used more than
greg you should get that rash checked
out is
what the hell is critical race theory
and why are we forcing it down
everyone's throat
like butter at brian stelter's dinner
table it's spreading everywhere
from classrooms to human resource
departments
look under a rock and there it is right
next to joy behar
it's even infected our military you know
the military used to have two objectives
kill the bad guys and blow up their
stuff
to that we've added a third understand
white rage
on the issue of critical race theory i
do think it's important
actually for those of us in uniform
to be open-minded and be widely read and
it is important
that we train and we understand i want
to understand white rage
and i'm white and i want to understand
it what is it
that caused thousands of people to
assault this building
and try to overturn the constitution of
the united states of america and i
personally find it offensive
that we are accusing the united states
military our general officers
our commission non-commissioned officers
of being quote woke
or something else because we're studying
some theories that are out there
little grandmothers were trying to
overturn the constitution
glad we arrested him and sentenced one i
miss the days when generals would be
nuking this nonsense
instead of defending it so he wants to
study crt as if it's something rare like
a rational cnn host
but you know there's other stuff
soldiers could be studying like how to
say halt
in chinese in russian or detect actual
threats to our country
for example threats like a pernicious
half-baked theory
that divides a country into oppressors
and oppressed using nonsense terms like
white rage
that amount to a cultist
pseudo-scientific indoctrination
white rage sounds like some sort of
steamy hot latte you can get at sheldon
whitehouse's country club
but it's scary that so many of us have
never heard of this crap and it's
spreading in the military faster than a
case of crabs
you know when those guys get out of the
crate there goes your supper
now if you want to destroy a country
the first step would be to get the its
military to incorporate
race-based self-immolation china
couldn't have done it better if they
were behind this
maybe they are wouldn't be the first
deadly agent to originate in china and
then go viral in the u.s
one of the colts defenders the proudly
bigoted joy reid
finally agreed to debate the white crt
critic
whom she smeared based solely on his
race
i wonder if she lets him talk you're
really just having a campaign
to take everything that annoys white
americans
no that's not right you want to make a
campaign and stuff
everything is my highlight you played my
highlight you'll give me a chance to
respond
and you absolutely stuff it all into
critical race theory i'm fighting
against you
you're fighting against wokeness and you
don't like that
hold on hold on no no no no no let me
respond at least once i haven't gotten
the full sentence
it's intersectionality theory which was
invented by kimberly it's a
separate thing
64 of americans now know what critical
race theory is no they know what
christmas
of which 58 of them you made up your own
you made my friend you made up your own
thing you admitted you were going to do
it
she's quite the host she seemed so
confident in her beliefs that she
couldn't let the other guy speak
and of course there's this chap who tees
off on white people so often he needs a
caddy
i agree with brother tim and speaking
about
you know the maggots i'm sorry the magga
um that is so corrosive
in this you know political uh moment i
resent
as an intellectual and as a black person
in america
that we have taken the brunt of
anti-intellectualism
we have borne the brunt of being
disloyal to this nation
and we have stood by to see mediocre
mealy-mouthed uh snowflake white men
who are incapable of taking critique who
are willing to dole out
infamous repudiations of the humanity of
the other
and yet they call us snowflakes and they
are the biggest flakes of snow
to hit the earth
i get it magga sounds kind of like
maggot
that's comedy professor so this guy who
keeps calling himself an
intellectual thinks that racist ad
hominem attacks against white people
constitute an actual argument
he hates whites more than my wife
holding a pair of my boxers on laundry
day
so as the media mocks critics of a
theory that the media doesn't even
understand
who's left to defend america from the
scourge the parents
seeing like the media parents have
something of value to lose
something called children now i'm not a
fan of children i hate them
they stink they're loud they get to
board first on airplanes
but you ever see how parents act when
their kids are being threatened
they're more competitive than joe biden
being told to wake up from his nap
do your job
[Applause]
goodness it's like an outtake from
footloose
what you're seeing is people waking up
to the woke people rising up to fight an
ideology designed to divide a country
but in order to fight something you
first have to be able to describe it
whether it's racism or cavities truth is
crt
is just one beastly tentacle of white
liberal supremacy
it's all based on an idea that black
people are incapable of achieving
anything on their own
so why not let the superior white
liberal help you the c
in crt actually stands for condescension
a reoccurring theme
in the democratic party's platform voter
id is an example of this neo-racism
woke white liberals say that blacks
could be anything including president
yet the saint black people can't figure
out how to get a photo id
something the average 17 year old can do
the moment they want to buy beer
but maybe it's too late this stuff seems
to be everywhere in cornell there's a
course that suggests black holes
could be linked to racial blackness
the word policeman is now on a list of
offensive words at brandeis university
this is true climate change and it's one
the parents are feeling
first because they're closest to the
toxic fart filled wind
so maybe it's time for an educational
tea party maybe it's time to occupy the
classroom
let's make our schools and maybe our
military crt-free zones
where students and soldiers can learn
the full story of america
there are better ways to establish
racial harmony and true equality in this
country
and if children are indeed our future
it's time to keep the adults in charge
for a bit longer
and let the parents take control
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's
guests this former volleyball star
keeps insisting the panel get up and
rotate
box station host abby hornacek
even his thank you notes our best
sellers up in the air author walter kern
[Applause]
he switches to a shoulder holster on
casual fridays
former cia operative and portman square
group ceo mike baker
and she recently walked down the aisle
to get a flight attendant to bring her
more vodka fox news contributor cat tim
all right walter you are an intellectual
you are an academic
and you said something very very
poignant in the green room
and i thought to myself you should say
that here
because i thought you captured it in
terms of trying to define the true
essence
of critical race theory you have the
floor
mr kern well when i was a child in
lilly white rural minnesota um
which i'll admit is not the most
racially
mixed place okay so you were a bigot
yeah well
no i i was told by my teachers that out
there in america there existed something
called prejudice and bigotry
and that perhaps i would encounter it
someday
and i looked at my heart and i said i
don't have any mostly because at that
point i had no one to hate
except you know there were lutherans
there were swedes and there were
uh norwegians yes um i am lutherans
but but later on those are lutheran
audiences yeah yeah i i know
but later on when i was presented with
the opportunity to dislike other people
because of their color
i decided i wouldn't right i i stopped
myself
and i declared myself innocent of
bigotry and prejudice
the problem with critical race theory is
that if you think you
aren't a racist that means you are it's
a logical regression
it it doesn't allow innocence it doesn't
allow
a way out it's a suggestion that
even uh considering yourself above race
is white right uh now in the summer when
i'm less white i'm also less racist
apparently yes
um but but but it convicts you before
you've committed the crime
and there's no crime that you can you
know not commit
that will let you off the hook yeah it's
like throwing the witch into the uh
lake and if she drowns she's innocent
it's absolutely that
you know they usually does that all the
time yeah yeah
but it's not witches it's just you know
citizens who uh
well i'm not saying they don't deserve
it that's all i'm saying yes
you know abby welcome to the show i just
want to warn you this isn't like fox
nation where you can just use the f word
whenever you want
dang it yes so uh we want you to make
try to keep it clean
say dang it either oh man i i run out of
words i'm sorry
i gotta leave is this the exit yes yes
yes i
now but you might hit your head you're
very tall i didn't realize how tall you
are i am it's the heels
uh and my long and my legs yeah
absolutely so you're suggesting i should
wear heels
yes you can borrow them if you want they
look quite nice
what's your take on would you did you
know what critical race theory was
when people were talking about it did
you have to like because that's the
thing it's like when you say
you know what it is the people
practicing it will say no that's not
what we're doing
well i think we saw that in that
interview yeah exactly
like jerry springer i don't know i i
it's so hard to understand because like
you said you say
one thing and then someone's like well
that's not it and it's like we don't
have a cohesive
definition it's like what you're
supposed to do with masks once you're
vaccinated it's like what are we
supposed to do i don't
i'm not really sure and i think we're
seeing this microcosm
within like you saw with the with the
parent meeting it's just like that's
what the country is like right now it's
just a bunch of people
fighting um i don't know why we didn't
start that meeting with let's get ready
to rumble or you know there weren't kids
selling popcorn i mean it's
it's so interesting to me because no one
seems to understand it because
and no one can really argue for or
against it yeah i think it would make
the homework really easy
i disagree right like white plus person
equals bad
like that's math history who was
responsible for the civil war
i was like a plus for catherine
i wouldn't have to think but then the
problem would be i i wouldn't be
thinking
yeah but that's no that's a it's a great
point because if you
if if you can if you're clever enough to
read the room
and go like wow you know what i don't
have to work that hard if i just
agree with the theory and so every
answer is always
white is bad and will be irrevocably bad
i did that in college all the time i
found it with the no because it was all
based on deconstruction and if you just
did deconstruction
deconstruction is thinking you could get
an a in any class
mike you have like 30 kids right um well
in the u.s you mean yes yeah so this i
mean i do i do believe that you can
actually explain what critical race
theory is it's just that the opponents
as you saw
will say oh we're not doing that or
you've got it wrong so it's up to
the parents to read about it right which
is i think it's a really key point um
first of all may i just say that
president biden's tendency
to lean in and whisper yeah during this
is creepiest
yes it's like drag queen story hour
yeah it's not it's not a good thing and
i think he should change that
i think somebody should tell him come up
with a different uh
look uh but this uh is a
partly a result of the pandemic as a
result of the pandemic getting to this
issue with the parents
parents all over this country suddenly
started to have to pay attention
to what was being taught right that's so
true
because we didn't pay attention before
right i mean you know well okay that's
not fair my wife is
much smarter than i am always pays
attention i had no idea
yeah and so pandemic hits your
homeschooling
and suddenly you're interacting with the
lesson plans and the teachers on a
regular
basis and that's when i think a lot of
this started to really kind of bubble to
the top
but as a white person
i really can't have an opinion on
critical race theory i just i see no
upside to me saying anything at this
point
yes and that's coming from a guy who's
killed a lot of white people but that's
perfectly enough clearly
if you just weigh the percentages but
theories like this
are designed to shut you up exactly you
know the lexicon
you're not supposed to understand no if
you don't understand something after
this much talk about it
it's because they don't want you to
understand what right right it's an
enemy like the fog or the blob you can
never get your hands on it or calculus
or
or physics or don't spear mathematics
mathematics is good blob was an
underrated film yeah
the original one by the way with steve
mcqueen hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else